hey guys it is the fifth of every today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but use the show where we
bring you the awesome the exciting and
the downright frustrating let's start
with that last one it seems that
Nintendo's controversial content
creators program for YouTube isn't
exactly a flawless concept while the
plan was to ensure YouTube content
creators get some money out of their own
videos where before Nintendo was intent
on keeping all the ad revenue if
Nintendo own content was used there
seemed to be some caviar please include
the fact that you can't play any games
in the smash brothers franchise or
third-party games like Pokemon and
bayonetta and expect to get a cut of the
cash although Nintendo was saying the
scheme has had more requests than
expected getting something for your work
is always better than nothing popular
youtuber PewDiePie has been outspoken on
this issue saying the people who have
helped and showed passion to Nintendo's
community are the ones left in the dirt
the most there's just so many games out
there to play Nintendo games just went
to the bottom of that list on to
something a bit more positive metal gear
solid 5 ground zero sales on PC we refer
to as solid yeah you get it Konami
reported earnings for the nine-month
period ending December 31 apparently
ground zeroes gathered a good following
on PC since its released last December
but Kaname is still selling most of its
games on PlayStation 3 followed by
PlayStation 4 Konami also reported a
solid win for pro evolution soccer 2015
which came out on consoles last November
and they got a big helping hand from a
bunch of mobile games that you've
probably never heard of finally for
those of you who are fans of fighting
monsters as Japanese teenagers we
finally got to look at the spoon of five
today in a brand new gameplay trailer
the trailer features a look at the games
principal characters and setting with a
chunk of in-game footage it's all pretty
much what you'd expect out of persona
high school kids with mad powers and
presumably dramatic social lives only
this time in a bustling urban
kitty persona 5 director katsura hoshino
has said you can expect the story which
revolves around high school students
being chased by strange happenings the
plan is to create characters that are in
his words as large as life and a little
more ill-behaved persona 5 is expected
to come to ps4 and ps3 later this year
let me know down in the comments if you
like to look at the sauna 5 and why or
why not you can help you gain spot for
more news on things like a sapphist
Creed rogue on PC details and our
thoughts on dark souls 2 scholar of the
first sin that is it for me today but
tomorrow I'll have my five best stories
of the whole week ready to go for you so
do check back with me then